what are the chances of you being you
let's start with your birthday odds are
that you were born in August September
or July the most popular month for
birthdays well chances are slimmest that
you were born in February or April and
what about the day of the week you were
born it's most likely you were born on a
Tuesday Wednesday or Thursday turns out
most babies take the weekends off and
odds are greatest than you came into the
world all by yourself
there's only around a 3% chance of you
being a twin and a very tiny chance of
you being a triplets or quadruplets what
about your names even if you have a
relatively popular name like David or
Rachel Joe or Lauren there's still a
really slim chance that you even wind up
with that name how tall are you if
you're a guy that changes our greatest
that you're 510 and if you're a girl
you're most likely 5'4 and if we would
reverse those Heights there's less than
a 3% chance of a guy being 5'4 and a
girl being 510 in fact there's less than
a 1% chance for a girl to be 511 or any
height above and less than a 5% chance
forgot to be any height above 6 1 if you
were born in the US there's about a 13%
chance you were born in California and a
10% chance you were born in Texas
there's a 4 to 6 percent chance you were
born in Illinois Florida or New York and
less than a 3% chance you were born
anywhere else but taking into
consideration the entire world there's
less than a 1% chance that you're even
born in the US so really no matter where
you're from or how tall you are or what
your name is
one thing is clear you are incredibly
rare
[Music]
[Music]